kommen wir jetzt der dunkle materie
endlich auf die schliche einem us
forschungsteam ist eine spannende
premiere gelungen die forschung haben
die dunkle materie ganz in unserer nähe
im umfeld unserer galaxie der
milchstraße ins visier genommen und
dabei haben sie bislang unbekannte und
super spannende strukturen entdeckt
können wir jetzt die geheimnisse um die
mysteriöse dunkle materie lüften klicks
umsatz im future gegen uns dreimal pro
woche spannendes eines videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
dunkle materie ganz in unserer nähe doch
diese aufzuspüren und ihre merkmale und
verteilung zu analysieren das ist
forschungsteams weltweit bislang nicht
gelungen
dazu sagt dongo jungen der an einer
neuen studie zu diesem thema beteiligt
war
ironischerweise ist es einfacher die
verteilung der dunklen materie in großer
ferne zu kartieren als in unserer
nachbarschaft das problem
teile der nahen strukturen werden von
der milchstraße verdeckt und zum anderen
wird die bewegungen von galaxien auch
von anderen faktoren als der dunkle
materie beeinflusst große störfaktoren
also die sich gar nicht so einfach
heraus rechnen lassen wenn man nur
wenige galaxien ins visier nehmen die
kartierung von strukturen die sich in
unserer nähe befinden stellte bislang
also eine riesige herausforderung da
doch das us forschungsteam hat sich
diese herausforderung angenommen
mit erfolg herausgekommen ist dabei die
verteilung der dunklen materie im umfeld
der milchstraße mit dabei sind einige
zuvor unbekannte strukturen die
benachbarte galaxien verbinden heißt
also die fachleute konnten unter anderem
auch bislang verborgene materialströme
ausfindig machen können wir mit hilfe
dieser neuen erkenntnisse jetzt also
endlich die natur der dunklen materie
aufklären
rund 300 milliarden sternen daraus
besteht sie unsere heimat galaxie die
milchstraße sie gehört zusammen mit der
andromeda galaxie mit zu den größten
galaxien der sogenannten lokalen gruppe
weise zusammen bilden etwa 95 prozent
der masse dieses galaxienhaufens aus mit
dabei sind noch weitere 70 bis 500
kleinere galaxien zu der lokalen gruppe
kommen noch 100 bis 200 weitere
galaxienhaufen die dann alle zusammen
ein teil des virgo superhaufen
doch wie genau verteilt sich hier im
umfeld der milchstraße die mysteriöse
dunkle materie und in welcher dichte
genau diesen fragen sind die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in ihrer aktuellen studie nachgegangen
dafür nahmen sie sich eine künstliche
intelligenz zur hilfe zunächst mussten
sie diese trainieren damit diese
überhaupt in der lage ist eine solche
kartierung von kosmischen strukturen
vorzunehmen
dazu trainierten die fachleute die ki
mit einer großen menge an simulation die
wiederum die verteilung und merkmale von
galaxien dunkler materie und
interstellarer materie enthielten diese
übung wurden vor allem mit datensätzen
durchgeführt die infos zu ähnlichen
galaxien wie der milchstraße enthalten
tatsächlich gelang es so die künstliche
intelligenz ki zu einer großen hilfe
auszubilden dass neuronale netzwerk
wurde somit letztendlich in die lage
versetzt verschiedene charakteristika
von galaxien in zusammenhang mit dunkler
materie zu ermitteln so zum beispiel die
eigenbewegung entfernung und leuchtkraft
von galaxien und wie diese mit der
dichte und präsenz von dunkler materie
in ihrer nähe zusammenhängen ein großer
erfolg wie das forschungsteam schreibt
das system kann auf der basis des
gelernten auch im neuen daten
detaillierte strukturen erkennen und
einige lücken schließen doch erst nach
dem training der ki ging es dann ans
eingemachte die forschenden fütterten
das neuronale netzwerk mit daten des
sogenannten cosmic flow3 galaxien
katalogs darin enthalten rund 17.600
galaxien die sich im umkreis von 65
millionen lichtjahren um die milchstraße
herum befinden
auf grundlage dieser daten sollte die
künstliche intelligenz dann ermitteln
wie sich die mysteriöse dunkle materie
in unserem lokalen umfeld also in der
nähe der milchstraße verteilt und wie
deren dichte ist eine echte premiere
denn solch eine karte zur dunkle materie
in unserem lokalen universum gab es noch
nicht und die ki hat es tatsächlich
geschafft und eine detaillierte karte
dazu erstellt und diese enthüllt einige
spannende informationen zum einen dass
die dunkle materie sich in einer art
netzartigen struktur um uns herum
verteilt genau diese art der verteilung
konnten fachleute in der vergangenheit
schon entfernen frühen universum
beobachten und die aktuelle studie
offenbart weitere spannende und bislang
unentdeckte strukturen mit dabei unter
an
kleinere brücken aus dunkler materie
benachbarte galaxien werden laut der
fachleute durch diese neu entdeckten
brücken miteinander verbunden und das
hat selbst das forschungsteam überrascht
mit hilfe der neuen karte wissen wir nun
wo diese filament strukturen liegen und
können diese verborgenen brücken
zwischen den galaxien dadurch direkt
untersuchen und es konnte ein weiteres
bislang unbekanntes charakteristikum
dingfest gemacht werden
die gleiche richtung der sterne ströme
zwerggalaxien und kugelsternhaufen im
umfeld der milchstraße mit der lokalen
ebene astronomen astronomen man damit
einen bereich von rund 20 millionen
lichtjahren durchmesser
hier werden die milchstraße und die
andromeda-galaxie von zwölf großen
galaxien umringt unsere nächstgelegenen
großen nachbargalaxien sind also
bemerkenswert regelmäßig angeordnet
zudem konnten die fachleute noch weitere
strukturen mit hilfe der kalli aufspüren
so beispielsweise eine relativ leer
zonen im alle am rand unserer
milchstraße den so genannten lokalen
beugt dieser war den fachleuten bereits
im vorfeld bekannt doch die neue
kartierung offenbart einblicke in die
dynamik und die gravitative verbindung
solcher objekte dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam die geschwindigkeitsdaten
zeigen wie sich material vom lokalen
volt zu den nahegelegenen filament
strukturen und galaxienhaufen bewegt
frühere studien hatten bereits gezeigt
dass sich der lokale volt von uns aus
gesehen über 40% des himmels erstreckt
und direkt am rand der lokalen gruppe
beginnt fachleute gehen davon aus dass
der größte teil der materie in unserer
galaxie und ihren nachbarn ursprünglich
aus diesem lokalen beugt stammt auch
eine weitere bereits bekannte struktur
des lokalen kosmischen netzwerkes
beinhaltet die neue kartierungs und
beispielsweise eine brücke aus dunkler
materie zwischen dem bürger superhaufen
und der lokalen gruppe ein dunkler super
highway aus dunkler materie also wenn
bereits vor einigen jahren dingfest
gemacht werden konnte es handelt sich um
eine gigantische strömung also ein
brücken artiges filament dass sich vom
bürger cluster durch die gesamte lokale
gruppe zieht an der seite wird diese
brücke aus dunkler materie komprimiert
der grund die lokale lehre in unserer
kosmischen nachbarschaft dehnt sich aus
die künstliche intelligenz die das os
forschungsteam für seine aktuelle studie
eingesetzt hatte konnte zudem auch den
von ex wohl ausfindig
hierbei handelt es sich um ein filament
dass mehrere galaxienhaufen verbindet
für die fachleute sind diese nachweise
der beleg dafür dass ihre neue 3d karte
die dynamiken und wechselwirkungen der
unsichtbaren und sichtbare materie gut
erfasst das us forschungsteam freut sich
über diesen erfolg und ist optimistisch
das rätsel der mysteriösen dunklen
materie wieder ein stück weiter lüften
zu können
da die dunkle materie die dynamik des
universums dominiert bestimmt sie auch
unser schicksal heißt also im klartext
sobald wir die grundlagen und
gesetzmäßigkeiten verstehen wie sich die
dunkle materie heutzutage verteilt lässt
sich auch die geschichte unserer
kosmischen nachbarschaft konstruieren
mithilfe der neuen erkenntnisse der
aktuellen studie wollen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nun herausfinden wie unsere kosmische
umgebung zu dem wurde was sie heute ist
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam eine
solche karte des lokalen kosmischen
netzwerkes zu haben eröffnet ein ganz
neues kapitel kosmologische studien denn
wir können nun erforschen wie die lokale
verteilung der dunklen materie mit
anderen astronomischen daten
zusammenhängt hier meinen fachleute
unter anderem strahlungs emissionen mit
deren hilfe man der dunklen materie auf
die schliche kommt denn eine hypothese
zufolge könnte es so sein dass sich die
teilchen der dunklen materie gegenseitig
auslöschen und zwar oder der abgabe von
gamma oder röntgenstrahlung genau das
kann jetzt mit hilfe der neuen
kartierung ermittelt werden denn falls
dies wirklich so ist müsste die
strahlung jahr in denjenigen regionen
mit hoher dichte der dunkle materie
deutlich höher sein
sie ist und bleibt aber immer noch ein
rätsel die dunkle materie
denn was sie ist das wissen wir immer
noch nicht aber wir scheinen ihr so
langsam auf die spur zu kommen
großartige entdeckung dunkler materie
auf der spur mit einem unterwasser
teleskop anklicken anschauen und diesen
canaria abonnieren ticks umsatz im
future einfach ihr unter dem video oder
eben anderem video auf den abo button
klicken das ist vollkommen kostenlos
muss man immer mal wieder sagen also
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran